[Applause]
pretty pretty insane happy thursday
everyone it's almost the weekend and i
can't wait emergency room here i come
so a few days ago we played tape of the
incoming white house press secretary
calling all of us racists roll it
clarice
fox news was racist before coronavirus
they are racist during the coronavirus
fox news will be racist after the
coronavirus so there is nothing new here
so true now this
this should upset me i mean what did i
ever do to her well other than oppressor
by my very existence since i'm a
middle-aged white guy
middle-aged
but we've never even met i don't even
know where she lives unlike the supreme
court justices
by the way i'm mowing brett kavanaugh's
lawn on saturday
he pays me in beer
but once she becomes press secretary and
is asked if she still thinks fox news is
racist will she have an answer ready
will it be an honest one like hey that
was just tv
or will she dance around it like liz
warren does at a bonfire to celebrate
the end of winter
for a hint let's take a look at a past
democratic debate featuring old joe when
he still had a working brain in control
of his bowels
and is now vice president before she
wasn't hiding like a serial killer on
the run
it was hurtful
to hear you talk about the reputations
of two united states senators who built
their reputations
and career on the segregation of race in
this country you also worked with them
to oppose busing
and
you know there was a little girl in
california
who was part of the second class to
integrate her public schools and she was
bused to school every day
and that little girl was me
i didn't see that coming
harris calling biden a racist it was her
only memorable debate moment besides
getting crushed by tulsi gabbard
but did she mean it she seems so sincere
and it's hard for her to seem sincere
cat's hair is less fake
but she looked him in the eye and she
twisted the knife into that old white
racist you could feel it but could she
feel it did she mean it it's quite an
accusation so i hope she took it
seriously
it was a debate
not everybody landed punches like you
did though
it was a debate
so you don't mean it
it was a debate that the whole reason
literally it was a debate it was
there were journalists there covering
the debate
it was a debate
now i happen to think colbert had her on
because he heard she'll laugh at
anything including him
but you get it collie biden racist was
purely a theatrical device you know like
a gun on the set of an alec baldwin
movie
nothing will go wrong
to her it's totally acceptable during a
televised debate whether it's true or
not it's okay to smear someone as racist
if they make you the second most
powerful person in the world
after dr jill
he's got the prescription pads she's a
doctor
but it's the political equivalent of
slamming a folding chair over the back
of a competitor in pro wrestling it
looks devastating but it's just part of
the game
accepted politics it can ruin you
with harris the chair's real but the
personality is still phony
so what does that example tell you well
if jean-pierre is ever asked by our very
own dumb sob peter ducey
if she thinks he's racist
she'll likely say
that was in the past peter let's move on
to real issues which will reveal how
little these flaks take their own
opinions seriously it's like if one of
your friends started a rumor that you
beat your wife and then said hey lighten
up just a joke
but here calling people racist is a good
career path
it's quite a racket claiming
everything's racist to get a really good
job i believe we're leading the world in
really successful oppressed people
so how many people who use the word
racist are actually seriously thinking
about it at the time has anyone ever
responded to them hey could you please
give a specific example of my racism and
don't bring up slavery and jim crow on
light joe biden or davy crockett i
wasn't born then
my guess is they'll be quieter than the
set of who's talking to chris wallace
ah just gonna stew in that
so now the word racist is meaningless
because the people thrown around
throwing it around made it meaningless
it's the semantic equivalent of the fed
printing too much money the more they
put it out there the less value it has
remember when white supremacists used to
mean kkk
now it's larry elder
and what happens when you end up running
into someone you smeared as a bigot well
just like me interviewing a naked nba
player
it could get awkward
the heights
is a problem
roll it
hi uh i will have the cruelty free
potato chips a extra vegan milkshake and
a side of the free-range kale yeah hey
deb you don't remember me you told hr
that i was racist in that zoom call oh
that doesn't count zoom is not real i
was in line for a big promotion stop
getting mad at me don't you know that
getting mad at a woman is sexist you
know what
you ruined my career take your chips
i'm not paying for these cause these
potatoes were grown on indigenous land
see you later racist
wow
that was amazing congratulations we're
making you vice president of the company
amazing you're fired
racist
thank you for holding me accountable
appreciate your time
[Music]
dirtbag dad
a crowd favorite
meanwhile the wright once again learned
from the left and found their own smear
to drive them nuts what came from the
disney controversy in florida one word
groomer
before that i always thought a groomer
was the guy who did my bikini wax
shout out to julio
but now every lefty is a groomer because
it's a mirror of what the dems did with
racist or do every rich person racist
every white person racist every trump
rally racist everything on fox races
every dead president every monument
every name of every school every
podcaster every comedian racist racist
racist so fine then every left-wing
teacher is a groomer every left-wing
disney employee who wants gender studies
talked to toddlers is a groomer everyone
who defends the medicalization of
confused kids you're a groomer
everyone who owned their own island and
named their private plane the lolita
express is
okay that's a bad example
but you get it
groomer is the right answer to racist
you call us bigots we call you a groomer
but it's gonna get hard for the left to
figure out who's left to call racist
meanwhile real racists get off scot-free
so ultimately what should you do when
you end up running into somebody you
labeled who labeled you a bigot
well you sure as hell shouldn't reward
them by making a vice president
that would be
stupid that would be
very stupid you groomer
let's welcome
tonight's guests
he's got the face of an eighth grader in
his glove department host of the guy
benson showing boxes contributor guy
he's so shredded i use him in the
kitchen to grate
can't cheese rob smith rob smith
she's like a paper straw thin white and
she'll decompose in two months
fox news contributor character
and
the last time he slipped and fell the
grand canyon appeared my massive
sidekick in the nwa real television the
best
it's like guy town plus guy town so it's
guy town with a guy yeah it's guy town
guy guy town what does that mean
i don't know it sounds like a fun place
to go this weekend yeah
yeah town it was a group of dudes but
now it's just one guy and his name is
guy
talking about news watching baseball and
going voting he's an assertive
[Applause]
how much did you spend on those graphics
it was amazing 200 280
we had to let go three people from the
cafeteria to make it worth it oh it was
worth it they didn't do very much and
they always stared at me and you know
they're not supposed to look me in the
eye
they're so close to retirement but now
they're getting their pension next time
don't look at me
okay where am i guy scott here's the
deal
the kamala thing and the jean-pierre
thing both have something in common in
the sense that
they're just playing a game and when the
game when they when they cash out of the
game it's like no hard feelings but you
do call people racist so is that just
part of the game we're just supposed to
laugh it off because we're in the media
or there are people that can't come back
from that yeah and i think what was
telling was the very last thing that we
played in the clip from the incoming
press secretary where she went through
the whole racist litany she said there's
nothing new here that's true they have
like three moves and this is one of them
there's nothing new in smearing a bunch
of people as racist and like they're
running out of real estate here the
american people aren't really buying it
the new poll tested thing is ultra maga
or whatever that is right it's like it's
like a fundraising level for the rnc
silver gold platinum and ultra right
right that's sort of they're going to
lean into it and if you donate now you
get a free trumpy bear or something yes
but they really
have virtually nothing left and so
they throw out a very loaded word that
is very offensive and a lot of people
just shrug and roll their eyes and
that's their fault ultra mega sounds
like something i get at the pharmacy
you know you know what i mean no no
no
not making eye contact
rob yes is it a fair correlation like
when you saw people when they got when
they reacted to the phrase groomer it
was like this like a couple a month ago
whatever and they all freaked out it was
i found it highly entertaining because
now they got a taste of their own
medicine i don't believe all liberals
are groomers of course that's ridiculous
but it was just fun no it was fun
because they were so triggered right
this is the thing um
back to the kamala harris moment that
may be one of my favorite moments ever
in kamala harris history it's just like
the camera goes in it gets really quiet
it's like a telenovela like the music
starts and she says i was that little
girl yes and then the t-shirts remember
the t-shirts of her as a 12 year old
they go up on the website like
immediately yeah she said that that's so
fed the fastest t-shirt company ever no
it was insane and so the thing about
calling everything racist is the best
grift on the left that guy that wrote uh
ibrahimovic's candy the how to be an
anti-racist award
20 000 an hour to call white people
racist i really want that job
like i would love that job well god
you're racist fox pay me 20 thousand
dollars i'm not paying you
i'll pay you to call him a racist
he's stealing my sweater from the five
not allowed in guy town yeah guy town
tyrus
what's that question
what do you think the next smear is
going to be have you thought about that
yeah actually i did the next time you
make a shot at wrestling like that
you're going to be a smear in the bottom
line have you ever taken a chair shot
gut felt no but i got mike
your point was
it was fake
i didn't say that i i i carefully edited
that line i never said anything about
fake
yeah it that's one of the realest things
as it gets there's no nice way to hit a
guy over the head with the steel chairs
he takes this very personally i have to
be have you ever been hit with a chair
especially when you're the big guy they
think you can take four or five of them
because you're a big guy are those real
chairs
you know what no what no you know what
they're not and i'm going to bring one
tomorrow night on the show
[Music]
i was racist yes
you get twenty thousand dollars
[Laughter]
but with inflation that's what six bucks
yes
or half a bitcoin yeah
oh yeah
i know me too
they're saying everybody's racist right
and it's a shame because it's it's
usually people right now it's people in
the black community who are getting
these great jobs who are attacking
everyone calling buddy racist i think
but
sunny from the view remember her yes she
recently
tried to tear down a black woman for
being a republican she said a black
republican is an oxymoron right
that's about as racist as you get when
someone's skin color determines the way
the way they're able to think of their
ideals because apparently wanting small
government and to keep most of your tax
money
you can't be black and do that i mean
the i taking ideologies away from a
group
is the definition of racism yeah and
it's not coming from the right not gay's
not guy's not walking in and making a
comment about me going what are you
doing here [ __ ] go outside and park my
car yeah i mean but that would be that
is racist and horrible and obviously we
wouldn't see him anymore guyton will be
destroyed but they're doing it live on
tv yeah in your face and no one can
question them on it because
they just that they use that blanket to
say whatever they want there is racism
but it's coming from the left
attacking other minorities who have a
different set of opinions right and
that's ten times worse than someone
putting a cross outside your yard in my
opinion you know uh dirt bag another
great turn is dirtbag dead i think
that's not her
i mean i don't know who that ugly lady
is
it's like uh instant classes yeah i
cannot look like that what should if
peter ducey which he should do asks um
uh jean-pierre like hey am i a racist
what's what should she say i don't think
he should ask her if he's a rape man
i think that the question would be you
know can you
can can you be fair right and she can't
so obviously she can't i mean
i i just think this is it's go it's just
gone so crazy because obviously like you
said the word doesn't mean anything
anymore but it's obviously completely
unserious throughout if you look at
kamala i'm actually starting to get
jealous of kamala
because
like if i wanted to just sit around and
like not work and like just laugh at
stupid stuff like that
i would have to do so many whippets
and you mean the drug not the dog
no i meant the dog
most people like she gets to do nothing
just sit around giggling like moose that
describes like every stoner who works in
the back of a kitchen right but she's
the vice president right that's true
that's the dream it's just
again remember this was supposed to be
the return to normal yeah we have the
president a guy who doesn't know where
he is yeah and then we have the vice
president who just sits around laughing
she doesn't know what a joke is at least
no she figures if she just keeps
laughing at everything it'll match a
joke
yeah
yeah
it's like joe like laughing on cruise
control exactly that's true that's true
no foot on the pedal there
do they make that anymore i don't know
i'm talking to myself because we must
leave just for a short break up next it
feels like we're getting punked when the
disinfo czar tweets stuff that's
debunked hey dave hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else